christophe castaner face aux sénateurs
cet après midi le ministre de
l'intérieur vient d'être auditionnés par
la mission d'information du palais du
luxembourg
au menu les méthodes d'action et
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre en
cause notamment les violences policières
et la méthode controversée dite de
l'étranglement et seul tout en ménageant
les syndicats de police remontée depuis
plusieurs semaines contre leur ministre
de tutelle
on retrouve tout de suite il a famous ou
en direct du sénat il a faim opération
d'équilibriste cet après midi pour
locataire de la place beauvau
les accusations de violences policières
d'un côté la colère des forces de
l'ordre de l'autre qu'est ce qu'il faut
retenir de cette audition
absolument gregory c est tout à fait ça
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est livré à
un véritable jeu d'équilibriste devant
les sénateurs de conseils commission
sénatoriale alors il a tenu dès le début
de son audition a rappelé que le
gouvernement avait fait de la sécurité
une priorité ans il a fait il a dressé
un bilan il expliqué que dès 2017
le gouvernement avait alloué plus d'1 1
milliard d'euros à la sécurité alors
c'est là où on l'attendait christophe
castaner a commencé cette audition
également en montrant qu'il était du
côté des forces de l'ordre il a déclaré
qu'il n'y avait pas de police violente
qu'il n'y avait pas de police raciste et
puis il est revenu cette sur cette
fameuse méthode d'intervention à qui est
fortement contestée depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant la fameuse méthode
de la clé d'étranglement qui est
d'ailleurs mise en cause dans la mort de
cédric sonia en janvier dernier à paris
il a déclaré que cette méthode ne serait
plus enseignée dans les écoles de police
et qu' il y avait des réflexions qui
étaient en cours pour proposer d'autres
méthodes d'intervention je propose de
l'écouter
j'ai demandé à ce que soit lancé un
groupe de travail conjoint entre la
police et la gendarmerie pour passer en
revue les techniques d'interpellation
à l'issue de ces travaux et estimant la
méthode comme dangereuse le directeur
général de la police nationale m'a
proposé de surseoir à l'enseignement de
l'étranglement
d'ailleurs elle n'est plus enseignée
depuis le début des années 2000 dans la
gendarmerie nationale ni dans
l'administration pénitentiaire et donc
en conséquence avec laurent nunez nous
avons décidé de mettre fin à son
enseignement
nous avons également il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution ni de rétropédalage demander
un nouveau groupe de travail de faire
des propositions très vite d'ici le 1er
septembre pour trouver des alternatives
à cette méthode
je suis convaincu aussi que nous devons
faire monter en puissance la formation
continue des policiers et gendarmes sur
la voie publique et c'est pourquoi j'ai
décidé que les policiers et gendarmes
devraient désormais suivre un nombre
d'heures annuel minimal de formation aux
techniques d'intervention sans quoi il
ne pourrait plus exercer sur la voie
publique
christophe castaner qui arrive est très
fragilisée devant cette mission cette
commission sénatoriale il faut savoir
qu'il est très critiquée comme vous
l'avez dit par ses troupes et en même
temps il se murmure qu'il pourrait
perdre son poste après le remaniement
qui devrait se tenir après les élections
municipales dont que christophe castaner
qui est la première personnalité à se
présenter devant cette mission qui a été
constituée le 16 juin dernier devraient
suivre donc l'inspection générale aussi
bien de la police que de la gendarmerie
nationale ainsi que les représentants
syndicaux de la police qui devrait
également être entendues d'ici la fin du
mois de juillet merci les la femme ouzou
pour un ces précisions en direct du
palais du luxembourg à paris